the prosecution have been taking the
jury through the events of the hours
that led up to the death of dalian
atkinson who was of course
a well-known professional footballer
best known for playing
for aston villa now they were told that
it was
in the early hours of the morning back
in august uh in 2016 that mr atkinson's
behavior
on that night had been both distressed
and erratic and he was banging on the
door of his father's home
in telford demanding to be let in now
now neighbors had
seen what was happening and had been
alarmed and they called the police
and the police officers that attended
were pc
benjamin monk and pc marielle and betley
smith
both both from west mercier police
now pc monk had a taser and there were a
number of
confrontations uh when they knocked on
that door and daley and atkinson
answered we're told mr atkinson was
unarmed but pc monk deployed his taser
three times now the first two times that
he deployed it it was the jury
we're told ineffective it appeared to
have no effect on mr atkinson but the
third time that he deployed the taser
we're told it was completely effective
daley and atkinson fell
face first into the road and was
according to neighbors who
were watching what happened completely
unresponsive now the jury were told that
the normal cycle of a taser is
five seconds but that the taser user can
override that
by continuing to press the trigger and
that in this case pc monk did override
it
in fact the taser was deployed for some
33 seconds more than six times
longer than would be usual and then the
jury were told that pc monk
uh once stalin atkinson was on the
ground kicked him
twice in the head so hard that the
imprint of the police constables boot
laces was seen
on two parts of mr atkinson's forehead
we're told pc betley smith used her bat
on also to strike mr atkinson
while he was on the ground and the jury
were told that
pc monk was an experienced officer but
that he must have been
angry um that he was in this situation
and in kicking dalian atkinson to the
head he can only have intended
to cause really serious harm now by the
time
the ambulance arrived dalian atkinson
was unconscious by the time he got to
hospital
he was in cardiac arrest and he died a
short time later
the prosecutor said that she had taken
evidence from a
specialist a pathologist and specialist
in intensive care
whose opinion it was that were it not
for the extended third taser or the
kicks to the head
daily and atkinson would not have died
that night
now that is uh the jury we're told in
spite of the fact that mr atkinson was
suffering some health conditions at the
time he was in renal failure
and did have some heart disease now pc
monk
denies the murder charge and the
alternate charge of manslaughter against
him and pc betley smith denies assault
the trial is expected to last some six
to eight weeks